BENEDICT CHONG: My
name is Ben Chung.
I'm a Product Manager at Google.
And as a product manager, I
need to set expectations for you
all, my customers, I guess.
There's absolutely no
speaker notes here, nothing.
So all the bad jokes
are all my fault, OK?
All right.
So I'm going to talk
to you about moving
your data to Cloud.
It's actually easier
than you think.
Hopefully, by the end of
this, you will believe so.
Oops.
OK, I-- let me see.
So how many of you knew that
this was Google's mission?
All right.
About half, maybe.
So our mission is to make all
the world's information easily
accessible and useful.
The same infrastructure
that we are using
is now available to you
right through Google Cloud.
We're basically using the same
platform, same applications,
making it available as part
of the Cloud platform product
suite.
And it allows you to
make your company's data
available, accessible,
useful, getting value of that.
So here's what you
can do with your data.
You can run some analytics, run
some machine learning models
on it, create new services,
new products out of your data,
or your existing data, or you
can move your applications
to the Cloud from data center,
and make it more usable,
serve content from Cloud.
And also you can just store
data on Cloud for the long term.
We have customers
trying to store data
or planning to store in
Cloud for next 99 years.
But all these things
is possible only if you
can get all your data today.
Most of the data in today's
world is in data center,
not in Cloud.
And you realize
that it's actually
very hard to move data.
And one reason
why you're here is
that you're thinking, that
is really difficult because I
have a lot of data.
I have very little bandwidth.
There's a lot of
paperwork and red tape
I have to go through in order
to get network connectivity.
How many of you remember seeing
as part of the intro slide
show the notable Evernote?
Yeah.
So Evernote took
about seven months
to move a few petabytes of data.
They have a pretty large
team of people doing that.
So they basically wrote
their own applications
with the GCS APIs.
So it's kind of tough, even
with the kind of bandwidth
that they had.
So how you get your
data to Google Cloud
depends on the kind
of data that you have
and the kind of data sources.
The way we look
at the world today
is unstructured data,
which are files--
stuff on object or mass storage
devices in your data center
or structured data,
generally databases.
So the stuff we're
going to talk about--
unstructured data.
And for this I have my
colleague Ash who will cover it.
ASH AHLUWALIA: Thanks, Ben.
Thank you for joining
us this afternoon.
My name is Ash
Ahluwalia, and I'm
a Product Manager that
works on large data
moves over the network,
primarily unstructured data.
So one of the first questions,
or first couple of questions,
you'll need to answer when doing
a large unstructured data move
are one, how much data
are you looking to move?
And two, how much bandwidth
do you have to move it?
So just to give you
a sense of where
people land on this
spectrum in the room
today, how many folks here
have a connection to the Google
Cloud that is faster than
10 gigabits per second?
Faster than 10 Gbps
by a show of hands.
OK, a couple of folks.
How many folks have
a connection speed
that is slower than one gigabit
per second to Google Cloud?
OK, a couple of other folks.
How many people have no idea
how fast their connection is
to the Google Cloud?
OK, like 80% of you.
So you now know one
of the questions
that you're going to have to go
answer after hearing this talk.
So depending on where
you are on this spectrum,
your transfer can take anywhere
from seconds or minutes
to days, or even weeks.
So it's important to understand
the answer to these two
questions before you start doing
a large unstructured data move.
Now, this is a pretty
complicated graphic.
So let me boil it
down a little bit.
We can keep the y-axis as
how much data you're moving.
And on the x-axis, instead
of bandwidth, let's
come up with an easier
concept to grasp.
You can think of this data by
how far away it is from GCP.
So if you have data that is
sitting already inside of GCP,
or it's in another public
cloud vendor like AWS,
there's pretty high
bandwidth connections
between those public
cloud vendors.
And so even a moderately
large data set
can be moved pretty quickly.
So in that sense, the data
is pretty close to GCP.
Now, you can think
one step further away.
Let's say you have
an on-prem data
center with a typical connection
speed to the public internet.
And then you can even have
further afield data centers
that are in remote locations or
have limited or no connection
to the internet.
In which case, even
a small data move
is going to take a lot of time.
In that sense,
it's far from GCP.
So what we'll do today
is walk through products
on different ends
of this spectrum
and how you can use
them for your data move.
So we'll start with data
that is close to GCP
with a product called the
Cloud Storage Transfer Service.
So this product is
explicitly designed
to move data from public
cloud to GCP, whether that
is within GCP from
one region to another
or from another public
cloud like AWS to GCP.
Some pretty common
use cases for this
include people that
are archiving or saving
a backup copy to GCS as part
of their multi cloud strategy.
Some folks pull data
from other public clouds
into Google Cloud for analysis
in a tool like BigQuery.
And then finally, some
folks use this tool
to move data between
GCS regions as part
of their daily operations.
Now, in addition to pulling
data from S3 and GCS,
as I've talked about, the
Cloud Storage Transfer Service
can also pull data
from any data that
is public addressable on
the internet via HTTP.
In addition, it supports a
one-time transfer or a repeated
sync and is also available
in all regions where
GCS operates today.
So let's do a little bit
of a walkthrough of what
this service looks like if
you actually went to use it.
So to find it, you would
go into the Cloud Console,
and under Google
Cloud Storage, there
would be an option
called Transfer.
And if you clicked
on that, you would
see a summary of all the
transfers that are running
and are done, and you would
also have the opportunity
to start a transfer.
To start a transfer-- basically,
it involves three steps.
First, identify the data
that you want to move.
Second, tell us where
you want to move it.
And thirdly, tell us
when you want to move it.
It's just that simple.
So we'll walk through
an example here.
First, identify the
data you want to move.
So here, hopefully
you guys can see this.
I'll point it out to you.
You can pick an Amazon S3 bucket
and give us the credentials
that we need to list objects
and pull data from that bucket.
And then you can tell us what
prefixes to include or exclude.
And you can also use
S3 metadata to choose
what objects to pull over.
For instance, basing your
pull on last-modified time.
So if you want to only
pull objects from S3 that
have been modified in the
last week, you can do that.
The second step is to figure
out where to move this data.
And to do that, you can pick
essentially any GCS bucket.
And we support all
GCS storage classes.
Finally, you have to tell
us when you want to move it.
You have basically
two options here.
One is to just
move it right now.
Or you can schedule a daily
sync at a time of your choosing.
So for instance, if you
have a workload on AWS
that writes new objects
to S3 every day,
you can schedule a transfer job
to run every night at midnight
to sync those over to GCS.
So that's a little bit about the
Cloud Storage Transfer Service.
Now, the next step, on
this larger graphic here,
is if you have a presence in
a colo or even on-premise data
center that has good
connectivity to the internet.
In that case, we offer
a product called GSutil
that you can use to
push your data to GCS.
Gsutil is a command line
utility that is specifically
designed to help you push
data from a data center
that you are operating into GCP.
And because it's a
command line utility,
you can use it for
your manual workflows
or as part of a script.
You can also run it in a
background process, where
it's constantly syncing files
and directories to a GCS
bucket of your choosing.
Now in addition to the sync and
copy options we talked about,
Gsutil also operates
in a streaming mode.
So if you have a process that's
long running and outputs data
periodically, you can pipe
that output to Gsutil,
and it will push
it along to GCS.
Gsutil has a lot of options.
I'm not going to go
through all of them,
but I'll highlight a couple.
It automatically retries if it
encounters ephemeral network
errors or errors from GCS.
It also supports customer
managed and customer
supplied encryption keys.
And finally, it obeys
the object versioning
semantics that are typical
of most GCS clients.
So let's talk a little bit
about some of the questions
that come up when
people use Gsutil.
The first one is how do
I move my data quickly?
So there are a couple
of features that Gsutil
has to help you do this.
The first is using
multi-threading.
So you can use the dash m
flag to ensure that the Gsutil
process is running
multiple threads which
are pulling all of
your files in parallel
and pushing them to GCS.
Now, if that's not fast enough
to fill up your bandwidth
to GCP, you can also
split up and run
Gsutil on multiple hosts.
And by doing so, move
your data in parallel
across multiple
Gsutil processes,
and use up more
of your bandwidth.
And to do that, one
important thing to note
is that you'll have to manually
partition your data in advance
so that none of these
separate Gsutil processes
are stomping on one another.
Now let's say you did that.
One of the problems you
may encounter, especially
if you're moving a
large set of files,
is that there's one file,
and one Gsutil thread,
and one process moving it.
So if it were a really large
file, like a 100 gigabyte file,
you might sit there
waiting for that thread
to move byte by byte for
that really large file,
and it just takes too long.
So to address that
situation, Gsutil
has a feature called
Parallel Composite Uploads.
What it does is it
basically takes large files,
breaks them into chunks, and
moves all of those chunks
simultaneously to GCS.
Once they arrive at
GCS, those chunks
are now composited into
a single GCS object.
It does require a
little bit of setup.
You have to set some
environment variables
and compile a library for crcmod
before the host for Gsutil
is installed.
In addition, it is
important to note
that if you are using certain
storage classes for GCS,
it does incur additional cost
as these composite pieces are
put together.
So a couple of other
assorted questions
that come up when
people are using Gsutil.
The first is, how do I control
how much bandwidth it's using?
For instance, if I already have
workloads in my data center,
I don't want Gsutil to
use up all the bandwidth
that those workloads
need to use.
So how do I stop that?
Unfortunately, today,
Gsutil does not
have native support
for bandwidth throttle.
But you can use tools like
Trickle or your network
administration
controls to control
how much bandwidth Gsutil uses.
Another question
that comes up is
how do I preserve my
metadata, especially
if I'm trying to use
GCS or Gsutil to make
a backup of my data onto GCS?
To do that, you can use the dash
p option, which takes your file
metadata, your
POSIX file metadata,
and puts it into the
metadata of the GCS objects
as you copy them over.
Finally, some
folks are concerned
about overwriting
data that already
exists in the GCS bucket.
If you're concerned
about that, you
can use the dash n option, which
ensures that you do not clobber
any data that already exists.
So these are a couple of
little tools and tricks
that you can use with Gsutil.
There's actually a lot
more to read and understand
before you become
an expert on this.
So before I hand it
back to Ben, I just
want to highlight three things
that I covered off on today.
One, whenever you are
doing a large transfer,
think about how much
data you need to move
and how much bandwidth
you have to move it.
Secondly, take a look
at some of the features
we walked through today and some
of our extensive documentation
on these two products
to figure out
which features make the
most sense for the data
you're trying to move.
And thirdly, and most
importantly, in my opinion,
whenever you're doing
a large transfer,
always start with a
small sample of the data
that you intend to
move so you understand
what features make
sense for you,
how much it's going to cost,
and how long it's going to take.
With that, let me
hand it back to Ben
to talk about the furthest
end of this spectrum,
when you have a
remote data center
with limited bandwidth
or no connection
to the internet at all.
BENEDICT CHONG: Thanks, Ash.
All right, so what if
you are in a situation
where you have very
little bandwidth,
or even if you have
bandwidth, a lot of it
is taken up by other
workloads, or you're
in a situation where
there's no network at all.
So this is what we
call offline transfers.
So for that, we have
Google Transfer Appliance.
This is the first
hardware product
that Google Cloud is shipping.
How many of you have
been to Moscone West
and seen it in person?
Just less than a handful.
So we really have a real
appliance out in Moscone West,
on the showcase floor, that
you can actually touch.
It's a real appliance.
It has all 60 drives in it.
So this is a high
capacity storage server
that we ship to customers.
And the idea is that
you will lower your data
onto the appliance,
ship it back to us.
We upload it for you.
I want to focus on the use
cases because there is--
when we talk to customers,
a lot of customers
start thinking about
interconnect and so on and so
forth, or upgrading
your network bandwidth.
And we know that that's
a complicated process.
There's the budget,
there is availability,
and so on and so forth.
A lot of ISPs want you to
commit to a two-year period.
And then your CIO
comes to you and says,
hey, I want to try out this
machine learning stuff,
but I do not want to invest
in high bandwidth networks.
So what do you do?
We have had relatively
good customer success,
where we ship them
a TA 100, which
is the 100 terabyte appliance.
They load it with 40 to
70 terabytes of data,
ship it back to us.
And then with that
amount of data,
they can actually run
a pretty good machine
learning modeling exercise.
And after that,
they're happy enough
that they signed on with
us for the long term.
So this is really good for POCs.
You are not blocked
by the availability
of network interconnect, all
that kind of conversations
with the ISPs.
Another use case
is where customers
decide that they want to end
of life their on-prem storage.
And then they want to move
all their data to Cloud.
This is really good for them.
So we ship them this--
the big one that you see there,
load it with all the data,
ship it back to us.
And we throw in GCS, generally
[INAUDIBLE] for the long term.
How many of you
have seen our blog
where we talk about the
Schmidt Ocean Institute?
So believe it or not, there
are data centers on ships.
So this customer of ours--
we go on a cruise for
about a month or so.
The ship takes the
smaller appliance.
And they rack it in the ship.
There's actually a data
center in the ship.
They collect all the data.
And while they're
collecting data,
they're singing
into the appliance.
So once they reach port,
they ship it back to us.
And then we load it
to GCS, and then they
share it with the rest of
the researchers worlwide.
And then we have
customers-- and this
is the last use case for
monthly long batches of data.
So we have customers
with also poor networks,
or insufficient networks,
and they use this for it.
Now, Transfer Appliance is
available in the US today.
But we're generally available.
We announced it
about a month ago.
We are starting a pilot program
in the EU, European Union,
for you.
So how many European
customers are there here?
All right, cool.
So feel free to reach out to me.
Or you can sign up
with the link here.
We'll reach back out to
you and get you started,
once we kick off that process.
And it's going to be
in a couple of weeks.
All right.
So quick summary of
the onboarding process.
You go to Pantheon--
sorry, Cloud Console for you
guys, request an appliance.
We send it to you.
You configure it, set it
up, fill it with data,
ship it back to us.
We do the painful stuff
of uploading data for you.
And then the last step,
you decrypt your data
and move it to the location,
or the storage class,
that you want your data to
reside in the long term.
And then the Appliance-- after
the data has been uploaded,
we wipe it securely.
Common questions include,
what do you do beyond wiping?
We wipe, we repartition
the hard drives,
reformat the hard
drives, reinstall the OS,
in case our customers decide to
install some application on it.
Because we have heard, oh,
we are running Linux on it.
OK, I'm going to
install some tools.
But no, no, no.
So we reinstall the OS,
reinstall the application,
and then get it ready
for the next customer.
So essentially,
the next customer
will get a new appliance.
All right, so I'm going to
walk through what Ash did,
the overall
Appliance experience.
There, you can see
in Cloud Console,
if you go to the
Storage tab, there's
option now for
Transfer Appliance.
Fill out the form here.
It's good to know how much
data you want to move.
And please don't
submit multiple times,
because we process all
these things manually.
So it's kind of fun
to see you, like, some
customers-- if I hit
Submit more often,
we'll get more appliances.
We'll work with you.
There's actually a person
at the end of this.
So we will work with you to
ship you the right appliances.
And again, there's
another person--
there's another person
at the end of this,
so we will work with you.
So it's not a machine that
is going to shut you down
and [INAUDIBLE],,
these kind of things.
There's a real person,
and we'll make sure
that you get the best
support that you need.
This is a picture of the
back of the appliance.
And you can see the real
thing in Moscone West.
You can see there, it's
the standard power supply
connectors.
We have fiber optic ports here.
For them, we will
supply the transceivers,
should you need transceivers.
There are four copper
internet ports.
Now why do we have four?
This allows you to do
network aggregation.
So you can run at a throughput
of 40 gigs per second
of throughput so that
networking itself
is no longer the
limiting factor for you
to capture data
onto the appliance.
We have customers where the
internal network is only one
gig.
By running it at
four at a time, we
are able to achieve four
gigabits per second,
which is not too bad.
It allows them to capture
data quickly enough.
This is where we talk
about encryption.
So the data is
encrypted in transit.
We use AES 256.
There's no phone home at all.
The appliance is completely
disconnected from Google Cloud.
The key is generated
by you guys.
So as part of this setup,
you'll create a passphrase that
is used to generate the key.
The encryption key is stored
in RAM on the appliance.
So while you are capturing
data, the key is being used.
Once you power off the appliance
and ship it back to us,
the key is gone.
When you-- what
we call rehydrate,
which is kind of like
decrypting the data--
that is done within
your project.
And we don't have access to it.
So we provide a web-based UI.
You connect to the appliance
using a web browser.
Today, we support Chrome.
Don't ask me why.
And you can see the job
status, the available physical
capacity, as well
as network usage.
So you know something
is happening there.
We offer a few capture options.
So the first two options, Linux
capture utility and Windows
capture utility,
for situations where
you need to do a fair
amount of authentication
to access your data
sources, right?
In that situation, you will
have a new Windows workstation
or Linux workstation sitting
between your data source
and the transfer appliance.
And the capture utility will
read data from the data source
and push it to the
transfer appliance.
Mount NFSJ is essentially where
the appliance is able to mount
or where you allow the appliance
to mount your data sources.
And you'll pull the data
from the data source.
And the last option there,
which is new and pretty popular
because it is an easy concept,
this is where the appliance
itself can be configured
to be a Nance box, right?
So you can mount it through
NFS and just copy or sync data
to it.
And it's a very easy
thing to do there.
So again, this is
a screenshot that
shows a couple of
options in progress.
So the first option there,
you can see NFS clients
where the appliance is
acting as an NFS client
reading data from a NS box.
And second option there is
that we have exposed part
of the appliance as an NFShe.
All right.
So once you have captured
data onto the appliance,
you ship it to us.
This is actually the box that
you'll see in Moscone West
and we uploaded to
a Google bucket.
So the final step
is rehydration.
That's where you will run a
VM, a GCVM in your GCP project.
This way, you would
decrypt the data
and move it to the GCP
bucket of your choice
in the region of your choice.
So we don't control
where you move your data.
For example, you can decide to--
you have data in the US.
You want to move it
to a European bucket.
You've been to run
the appliance process.
And then when you
decrypt the data,
it can be stored into
the GCS bucket in Europe.
And this is a screenshot of
the UI with the rehydration
jobs running.
And finally, when
all is said and done,
we provide a summary
dialog that tells you
how much data was transferred.
And about files, we'll
highlight failures like,
you know, sometimes files are
missed because either they
are deleted or being
captured or there
are some integrity failures.
Integrity is where
we do a check sum.
So the source file
destination for we do a CR 32,
and we'll tell you if
a bit has been flipped.
So we are working with
a bunch of partners
for transfer appliance.
So here is one use
case where you're
using Commvault to back
up your data, right?
But the first initial
copies of backup data
can be so large that it's
not feasible to transfer it
over the network.
So you use a transfer appliance
as a backup target, backup
to transfer appliance.
We upload that initial backup
[INAUDIBLE] into a GCS bucket,
and then you will do the
deltas over the network.
So we're working with another
partner cohesively for a very
similar use case as well.
All right.
So this is kind of like a
summary of our own solutions
for data transfers.
Partner solutions.
So Google is very
partner friendly.
For online data transfers,
we have partner options
from Tervela, Aspera,
BigSpeed, and Komprise.
And for offline
options, like, if you
have too little data
for the appliance
because the smallest appliance
is about 100 terabytes.
What if you have about
five terabytes of data?
You can work with Iron Mountain
to ship the drives to them,
or a lot of customers have data
already stored on hard drives.
They can ship the hard drives
to Iron Mountain as well.
And this is another
interesting use case
where, if you were to
have active data sets that
are changing all the
time, you may not
want to freeze the data
sets of your workflow
just because you want to move
data to transfer appliance
or through other means.
So with Zadera Storage,
you can basically
take a snapshot of data,
moving it to the cloud,
and then sync in the back end.
All right.
So this is a summary
of [INAUDIBLE] options
for unstructured data.
So let's talk about
structured data next.
This next section is
very, very quick section.
We're covering Databases,
Datalake, BigQuery.
And this is basically
going to just give you
an idea of what's available.
I'm not going to go into
too much depth here.
And you'll see a lot
of logos flow by,
and that's because a lot of it
is through patented solutions.
So database migration.
What we are saying here
is that it's not just
about the data, right?
There's a few things
you need to think about.
The migration of the data
and schema is just one of it.
Database assessment,
data discovery.
The migration itself renders
the largest migration
because no database
lives by itself.
We're just going to cover
data discovery and data schema
migration here.
This is a redirection slide.
So where you can data
discovery with Informatica,
that's who we are
partnering with.
They actually have a session
after this where they will
cover what you can do here.
So the whole pont
of data discovery
is finding out what you have.
We find that since
the sum of cloud
you find out a lot of
teams in IT departments,
they can start cloud
products or cloud projects.
And the CIO or the
rest of the company
may not know what's out there.
So the idea here is to
find out what you have
so you can kind of figure
out what you need to do,
when you need to migrate over.
Here, we talking about data
schema migration, right?
Through Spanner and Cloud SQL.
So again, we have
a bunch of partners
that can migrate data and the
schemas from different sources
out there.
Now, if you're looking at
creating a datalake on GCS
with Dataproc, the
session out there is over.
But we-- all the
sessions are videotaped,
so you guys can
watch that online.
So again, we have partners
there to help move data
from either HDFS or other cloud
objects storage to GCS for use
with Dataproc.
BigQuery is, again, a bunch
of third party logos here.
Again, just to highlight that
Google is actively partnering
with a lot of other companies
to provide solutions
to our customers as you think
about leveraging clouds,
as you're thinking about doing
a lift and shift to cloud
for existing workloads.
And finally, this
is a Google product.
BigQuery Data Transfer Service.
So a lot of marketeers
are using the products
you see on the left here for
marketing campaigns and so on.
And BigQuery is a great
tool to figure out what
customers are actually doing.
How are they clicking?
How are they reacting with--
interacting with the ads?
Are they actually falling
through, and because you
have different data
sources, BigQuery
is a good way of combining all
of them, joining the data sets
and getting some
intelligence out of it.
All right.
So that's the end
of the presentation.
[MUSIC PLAYING]